the american psychological association
says many adults are emotionally
overwhelmed and exhausted after more
than two years of the pandemic in fact
87 percent of people in a recent survey
feel there's been quote a constant
stream of crises in the past two years
so let's talk about solving that in her
new book homecoming overcoming fear and
trauma to reclaim your whole authentic
self clinical psychologist and professor
tama bryant looks at how we can get out
of what she calls survival mode a mode a
lot of us know well professor bryant
also happens to be president-elect of
the american psychological association
and she joins us now it's so glad to
have i'm so glad to have you here oh we
all need this right now yes people are
really struggling so thanks for having
me so the book is called homecoming what
is a homecoming yes so stress and trauma
disconnect us from ourselves so to come
home is to heal and to reconnect with
the truth of who we are instead of just
being in survival mode yeah it's not a
physical place that's right it's not a
geographical place yes i think you are a
uniquely qualified dr bryant because not
only are you a doctor psychologist
you're also a minister in the black
community as you know most people would
call their minister first before they
would call a psychiatrist or
psychologist
so how do you even know when you're in
need of of a homecoming it's a great
question because many times we're so
busy going through life we don't really
check in with ourselves you think being
busy is good right and so you can be
busy but not healed you can be
productive and disconnected so you may
have symptoms of depression you may have
irritability you may be feeling anxious
and then we also could be numb just
going through life life is happening to
you but you're not really present and it
can also show up in our actions if we're
medicating with substances or sabotaging
ourselves i like to say when i'm
standing on my own wings i'm in need of
a homecoming
so when you you're looking to reconnect
with yourself what are the first steps
to doing so the first step to
reconnection is telling myself the truth
sometimes we don't just lie to other
people we're not even aware of our own
despair about you denial's never healing
or transformative that's right if i'm in
denial i can't heal it and so to come
home begin to tell yourself the truth
and to live from that truth to take
better care of yourself and also to
choose affirming relationships because
if i'm around people who stress me out
all the time it's going to be hard for
me to be at home within myself yeah i
like how you said breakups can break you
that's that that's one of my favorite
chapters but the thing that one of the
things many things stood out to me about
your book it's very well done by the way
you say that many people use it as a
badge of honor i went through this tr
this stress i went through this trauma
and i've grown from it you go no that's
not the way to look at it
if there's a term post-traumatic growth
and so the trauma is not the thing that
made you wiser or stronger it is your
internal resources and the supports that
you had along the way that help people
to heal because the trauma in and of
itself is devastating but we pull the
wisdom out of our wounds
a lot of people are dealing with
physical losses with the pandemic but
also these invisible losses losses of
time and opportunity how do you deal
with those those are important to grieve
as well we call it unrecognized grief so
yes grief the loss of a loved one but
the lost opportunity the lost connection
the lost time lost community it's
important to get back home to yourself
so that you can reconnect yeah all right
well done she has little homework
assignments at the end of every uh
chapter you give great examples
involving your own life story bravo
bravo and a phd trained at harvard
medical school a minister i mean if you
were a pastry chef that's the only other
thing i could imagine might be more
comfortable and she dances and tony you
love biscuits yeah
damo bryant thank you very much
homecoming is on sale now